I'm Tony Stark  I build neat stuff I got a great girl  and occasionally save the world so why  can't I sleep  you elected me on a single platform I  will defend this country at all costs  the Mandarin must be stopped  you don't know who I am  you'll never see me coming  what do you want to do about these tax  the whole world's gonna be watching the  question where is Tony Stark  things are different now I have to  protect the one thing that I can't live  without that's you  mr. stark  today is the first day  it was the left of your life  I'm going to offer the choice do you  want  and teal life  or a meaningful death  you're not man nothing more than a  maniac  I'm not afraid of you so politic here  just good old-fashioned revenge  we do need backup that's your department  here's my boys